hey everyone so today in the office I
thought why not shake things up with an
interesting game of would you rather I'm
going to be asking some co-worker some
rather unusual would you rather question
so let's see what they have to say would
you rather have your girlfriend switch
bodies with your dad for a year or would
you rather switch genders for two years
oh I rather switch genders for two years
yeah yeah I don't I don't want to heat
my girlfriend in my party you'll just be
a beautiful woman yes thank you for your
confidence would you rather be pregnant
for two years or have your period for
two years oh I would rather be pregnant
for two years because I could get away
with eating whatever I wanted there
period for two years my god oh no maybe
like Tampax will sponsor you or
something think of all the sex you
couldn't have would you rather watch
your parents have sex every day for the
rest of your life or join them once I
would get used to it
there are so many questions that go into
this how long are they going to take
what would I have to do I really value
my time and so even though it would be
horrible I would probably just join them
one so that way I would never have to do
it again you're a brave soul would you
rather fart every time you told a lie
and very loudly or sneeze in your
crush's face every time they entered a
room these are awful I like people so I
wouldn't want to sneeze in my crushes
face all the time
it would just encourage me I guess not
to lie so I think I'd go with that one
would you rather have your ex's name
tattooed on your body or refer to your
partner only by pet names to them to
everyone forever
tattoo thing is like can you get it
covered up until like a sick dolphin or
something or
No then I'm gonna call the person I love
by the pet names
I had a I had a boyfriend who I used to
call poop that's that's really romantic
cute I think yeah we don't care what you
think so those were their answers which
one of these things would you rather do
leave a comment below with your answers
and I'll see you real soon would you
rather have teeth for pubic hair or
pubic hair for tea